حلفوا الكرملين الاول مينز يكشف عن قدرات
بعض جنوده العسكريه بعد مرور عام على
الصراع في اوكرانيا ما هي هذه القوات وما
هي قدراتها وكيف تجري تدريباتها العسكريه
العربيه اول فريق يدخل الى القاعده ثمانيه
وثلاثون للانزال والهجوم الجوي على الحدود
البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه والبيلاروسيه
البولنديه
عشرات الجنود البيلاروسيين تبعثروا في
باحه الميدان العسكري ولكل منهم مهمته
الخاصه
[تصفيق]
نحن القوات البيلاروسيه مستعدون دوما
للدفاع عن بلادنا مهما كانت الظروف صعبه
ومهما تغيرت المهمات القتاليه
خطط الهجوم الجوي ظهرت بوضوح خلال عمليات
التدريب مهام عده لرفع قدرات القوات
تقوم الان بعض فرق الانزال باجراء محاكاه
للسيطره على منطقه حدوديه من مهامها انشاء
خط دفاع حسب روايه القائمين لحمايه حدود
البلاد
نحن نفتخر بكوننا احفاد ابطال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ولهذا نحتفظ في مدخل
قاعدتنا بالكثير من قطع اجدادنا العسكريه
في الداخل معرض سنوي لذكرى الاجداد مهمه
تحضير طويله مرتبطه بعمر الازمه بين موسكو
والغرب عبد الجواد الروشت العربيه بريست